[Musique]
ces ondes du 7-8 sport votre magazine
consacré à l'actualité sportif dans les
yvelines c'est parti pour le sommaire il
a réalisé son rêve traverser le salar
d'uyuni le désert de sel en bolivie à
seulement 20 ans thomas d'eric
originaire de montigny le bretonneux a
parcouru 140 km en 6 jours conditions
climatiques et physiques extrêmes
il a filmé son aventure le document a
retrouvé dans ce magazine du cyclisme
sur route sur piste et du baseball au
retour sur plusieurs événements sportifs
de l'été avec le départ de la dernière
étape du tour de france depuis
rambouillet où la fin de saison des
cougars de montigny le bretonneux en
baseball
c'est la rentrée pour les clubs
yvelinois notamment en football et en
rugby trap a repris le championnat pour
le rugby club de versailles ce sera ce
week end une saison particulière pour
ces deux clubs
ils sont montés en division supérieure
la saison dernière nous sommes allés les
rencontrer pour faire le point sur leurs
objectifs
nous recevons aussi steve salagnac il a
parcouru les 12 stades de football des
clubs londoniens professionnels en trois
jours il nous rend con il nous racontera
son expérience dans cette édition met
tout de suite retour sur les
performances et les résultats sportifs
de l'été et du week end
[Musique]
c'était l'un des événements majeurs
durant l'été le tour de france la
dernière étape du tour a été organisée
au départ de rambouillet dans les
yvelines le 28 juillet dernier des
milliers de supporters de toute la
france et même du monde était présent
pour voir la fin de la grande boucle
michael et demi d'euros et mélanie poker
et vitrines vélo maillot rambouillet est
aux couleurs du tour de france dimanche
28 juillet la grande boucle fait escale
dans la cité royale à l'occasion du
départ de la dernière étape vers paris
une première depuis juillet 2012
ce que du bonheur c'est l'aboutissement
de huit mois de travail
mais l'équipe high tone naturellement et
puis une centaine bonne centaine de
bénévoles
effectivement c'est du bonheur parce que
on va enfin vivre cette journée est
renvoyée tant attendu pour les rambos
littamé pour le territoire et pour
beaucoup de visiteurs nationaux
le rendez vous a attiré plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de spectateurs sur
cette journée l'occasion pour ces
aficionados du vélo d'approcher les
coureurs qui les ont fait vibrer cette
année on habite en région centre et on a
pas d'étape à côté de chine d'accord
donc on est obligé de faire deux heures
de route pour venir les voir
j'espère rencontrer beaucoup de coureurs
que j'aime bien que je voudrais d'avoir
devant moi parce que à la télé c'est
bien d'y voir be
des vins de saint parres mieux celui que
tout le monde veut voir c'est lui et
gagne bernal à 22 ans le coureur
colombien est presque assuré de
remporter le tour de france avant le
départ à rambouillet il doit juste
terminer l'étape
un résultat qui enthousiasme les
milliers de supporters colombien présent
dans les yvelines
[Applaudissements]
je suis très très heureux c'est l'un des
plus grand jour de ma vie c'est une joie
très grande c'est la première fois qu'un
sportif colombien remporte le tour de
france c'est quelque chose de très
important et nous sommes fiers de
représenter notre drapeau et notre pays
une fois les signatures et laissez-les
fit terminer direction la ligne de
départ pour les spectateurs pour voir le
départ de la caravane et de ses 160
véhicules décorés aux couleurs des
marques elle les coureurs s'élancent
ensuite à 18h10 depuis le parc du
château de rambouillet et en direction
de paris
les yvelinois reverront le tour de
france l'année prochaine une convention
a été signée par le département pour
accueillir la dernière étape de la
grande boucle jusqu'en 2023
c'est désormais une tradition le
département a accueilli la 19e édition
du paris brest paris entre le 18 et le
22 août un rendez-vous cyclotouriste
organisée tous les quatre ans des
milliers de sportifs venus de 66 pays se
sont élancés de la bergerie nationale
dans le parc du château de rambouillet
ils ont traversé cinq régions et 180 une
commune
on écoute l'un des organisateurs au
micro de gwenaëlle saintilan en terme de
fréquentation
un niveau de participation jamais connu
cette année un 6674 participants 534
femmes 66 pays représentés
c'est tout je sais que c'est passionel
un petit un petit aménagement a fait on
avait malheureusement que 22% des
français ce qui
ce qu'il faut c'est un chiffre un peu
bas pour une telle randonnée sur le
territoire français laurie berton 27 ans
et sandie clair 31 ans toutes les deux
décidé de mettre un terme à leur
carrière de cyclisme sur piste
laurie berton s'est notamment une
médaille d'argent en omnium lors des
championnats du monde à londres en 2016
sur les réseaux sociaux elle explique
que son moteur a toujours été le plaisir
et qu'elle le trouve de moins en moins
sur son vélo du côté de sandie clair
elle a décidé de prendre sa retraite
suite à une décision de la fédération
française de cyclisme l'arrêt de la
vitesse par équipes dames
à un an des jeux olympiques de tokyo une
déception pour la spécialiste française
de cette discipline qui regrette aussi
que la fédération ne lui laisse pas sa
chance sur les épreuves individuelles
un mot de baseball à présent la saison
de première division s'est terminée au
mois d'août
les cougars de montigny le bretonneux se
sont finalement classé à la cinquième
place du championnat avec un bilan de
cinq victoires et 13 défaites
une petite déception pour le club
finaliste l'année précédente et
européens cette année on écoute
l'entraîneur de montigny le bretonneux
rodolphe le meur au micro de michael et
demi d'euros une cinquième place sur 12
on pourrait dire que c'est pas atterri
mais pour nous c'est très bien on va
maintenant pour l'année prochaine se
concentrer justement pour aller chercher
une nouvelle coupe d'europe pour 2021 et
on va faire le recrutement qu'il faut
pour ça il ya des petites choses qu'on a
vu cette année donc on va on va devoir
changer
il va falloir encore hausser le niveau
de l'équipe est allé chercher deux des
joueurs encore beaucoup plus constant
pour pouvoir se frotter justement aller
chercher cette cette coupe d'europe et
c'est finalement rouen qui a remporté le
championnat de première division
on reste avec du baseball avec un match
international organisé fin août à
montigny le bretonneux des japonais sont
venus jouer une rencontre amicale contre
l'équipe de france au stade jean
maréchal dans le cadre d'un tournoi
un reportage de michael et ni d'euros
[Musique]
l'hymne national japonais a retenti au
stade jean marc et celle de montigny le
bretonneux une équipe composée de
joueurs de ligue industrielle est venu
disputer un match contre l'équipe de
france représentant japonais nous
voulons bien figurer sur le terrain pour
remporter ce match et faire honneur à la
sélection de notre pays
pour moi le but aujourd'hui est de
gagner mais surtout de représenter
fièrement l'équipe japonaise
il faut être au top tous les jours cette
rencontre internationale est une
première pour la ville c'est très très
rare de les avoir c'est vrai en france
parce que le voyage déjà un fou qui se
déplace et on les a déjà eu il ya deux
trois ans et c'est vrai que c'est très
rare qui viennent mais c'est vraiment
exceptionnel de les avoir en français
pour voir ce spectacle près de 120
personnes ont fait le déplacement
je connais pas du tout le baseball et
c'est un sport que je trouve sympa à
découvrir donc ça change vraiment
chouette quand j'étais au japon je joue
au baseball
aujourd'hui je suis vraiment heureux de
voir un match de baseball l'occasion
pour les spectateurs de voir également
les joueurs locaux aujourd'hui deux
joueurs des cougars de montils routes ne
sont présents le troisième base daniel
patry c'est le lanceur antoine euros
c'est très très important pour nous
aujourd'hui de pouvoir développer le
baseball encore plus à montigny plaisir
devant ses supporters tête devant un
public aujourd'hui qui est quand même
nombreux donc c'est bien pour le
baseball français pour montigny le
bretonneux
le match s'est finalement terminée par
une victoire des japonais sur le score
de 22 à 0
montigny le bretonneux sera à nouveau
candidat pour accueillir une nouvelle
sélection nationale dans les prochaines
années et on accueille steve salagnac
sur notre plateau bonsoir bonsoir
alors avant de revenir sur votre
expérience avec une course à pied autour
des 12 stades de l'équipe
professionnelle de londres
pendant trois jours je vous propose un
tour des résultats sportifs du week end
et on commence avec le championnat de
nationale 2 pour le compte de la 5e
journée le fc mantois affronter fleuri
les yvelinois se sont inclinés 3 0 sur
leur terrain une défense montoise
débordé par la vitesse des attaquants
essonniens de leur côté poissy est allé
chercher un match nul sur le terrain du
fc lorient 2 sur les cinq premières
rencontres les pisciacais compte une
victoire deux nuls et deux défaites
au classement on ne retrouve aucune
équipe yvelinois dans la première partie
du tableau
une poule dominée par chartres poissy
pointe elle à la 11e place alors que les
mantois occupe la dernière place du
classement avec cinq défaites en cinq
matches comme vous pouvez le voir à
l'écran début de saison fantastique pour
versailles en nationale 3 ils ont
remporté ce week-end le derby yvelinois
face aux mureaux le score 3 0
au classement les versailles et occupe
la première place
quatre matches quatre victoires aucun
but encaissé mais ils ont fait trembler
les filets 10 fois en ce début de saison
alors moi je vais vous poser une
question pour commencer cet entretien
comment mélanger sa passion pour le
football avec le running tout simplement
en mettant en place ce type de projet
voilà des courses original où vous
pouvez voir par exemple de stade en
stade ce qui peut vous permettre de dans
certains cas des coréens stade
bon nous on les connaissait déjà avec
mon collègue pour la plupart meiway par
exemple mettre en place ce type de
projet alors mélangés le running elle
football pourquoi parce que vous avez
relier les 12 stades 12 stades des
équipes de football professionnel de
londres en trois jours ce qui représente
115 km de course à pied alors vous êtes
un ground hopper littéralement à
chazelles un chasseur de stade en quoi
ça consiste en fait la grande peur c'est
des personnes qui sont passionnés par
justement les stades
tout ce qui a attrait au tour des clubs
tout ce qui est tout ce qui est
géographique aussi
voilà peut-être un petit peu moins parle
par les matches donc nous ce qu'on aime
voir cesser les stades alors on a vu le
parcours s'afficher en tout cas les 12
stades la liste des douze stades de
s'afficher à l'écran
si je vous dis l'olympic stadium on dit
c'est le stade de west ham west ham ou
notamment on a vu évoluer
dimitri payet ces dernières années avant
qu'il rejoigne l'olympique de marseille
stamford bridge chelsea chelsea et le
selhurst park un peu plus compliqué
crystal palace crystal palace qui occupe
actuellement la quatrième place de
première ligue
comment vous avez vu cette cette idée en
fait d'aller voir les 12 stades
londonien alors bannu à la base
comme on l'a dit on est des grands
docteurs les passionnés de stade mais
moi et alex on est aussi des coureurs on
court beaucoup donc un jour et nous est
venue l'idée spontanément comme ça de
relier des stades et puis ben à londres
et de londres est venu comme ça mon ami
et va très souvent à londres il va
généralement de trois fois par an donc
voilà spontanément comme ça on s'est dit
on va régler tous les stades alors
comment ça s'est passé vous êtes parti
le 10 août c'est ça le disais tout à
fait et vous avez donc terminer votre
séjour
le xiii 115 km vous avez comment vous
allez organiser ces trois jours en fait
alors mon collègue lui à gérer tout ce
qui est parcours après au niveau de
l'organisation on a essayé de faire
quelque chose d'à peu près équilibré
donc c'est à dire que les deux premiers
jours on a fait 35 km au niveau des
stades dans mon a fait 5 4 et après 3
voilà et la dernière boucle pour ce soit
un petit peu fun on a fait une distance
marathon 42 km et c'est quoi l'objectif
de cette initiative il ya quelque chose
derrière ou c'est juste pour le plaisir
vos plaisirs personnels votre passion
aussi vivre votre passion à travers ce
voyage
alors voilà y'a deux buts le premier
c'était c'était effectivement le plaisir
le second c'était aussi caritatif
puisqu'on a représenté une association
qui l'association courir pour marie le
but premier était de leur donner de la
visibilité
donc je pense que ce que c'est ce qu'on
a réussi à faire c'est quoi courir pour
marika quel est le but de cette
association c'est une association qui
permet à des enfants handicapés et
polyhandicapés de participer à des
courses chronique justement donc via des
ce qu'on appelle déjoué à l'aide des
fauteuils adaptés alors quelques
anecdotes peut-être à nous raconter vous
avez assisté au premier match de la
saison de fulham alors fulham c'est un
club qui évolue en seconde division mais
c'est quand même un début de saison
comment ça s'est passé est ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter ce moment au niveau
de la prise de contact avec fulham la
prise de contact et puis après le moment
en lui-même
ben en fait c'était assez particulier
parce que nous on s'attendait pas à
recevoir un accueil comme ça on était
venu simplement voir le match qu'on
était invité et puis on s'est rendu
compte en arrivant qu'on était en
tribune de presse
donc on avait accès à tous
tout ce dont ont accès les journalistes
c'est à dire qu'on était en tribune de
presse avec les écrans les programmes de
match et c'est donc c'est un peu peu
particulier un autre stade aussi qui est
emblématique de londres c'est stamford
bridge alors pourquoi justement vous
pouvez nous dire pourquoi il est
emblématique ce stade
d'une part parce que c'est un club prêt
même important à londres mais il ya
aussi le lieu où il est situé bah c'est
un stade qui est situé qui est située
quasiment en plein centre donc c'est un
stade qu'on voit qu'on voit pas
forcément d'extérieur comme quand vous
êtes à 200-300 mètres vous ne vous
rendez pas compte qu'il ya un stade ici
en fait et c'est quand on arrive dans
l'allée du stade où on voit tout les
fresques et ceara est effectivement
qu'on qu'on le voit que qu'on voit que
c'est particulier physiquement comment
ça s'est passé parce que vous l'avez pas
fait en marchant à vous laver comme on
le rappelle avait fait une course à pied
il eu quand même un peu de marche
emplacement tierces que sur les 115 km
effectivement on fait pas que courir
mais physiquement c'était un peu un peu
délicat les deuxième et troisième jours
surtout que moi j'avais un problème au
genou donc deux mois avant je me suis
blessé et jusqu'aujourd'hui je savais
pas quelle distance je vais pouvoir
faire donc c'est un peu délicat à gérer
d'ailleurs j'ai fini les 7 derniers
kilomètres moi personnellement aux vélos
électriques ce qui était assez rigolo
sinon après mon collègue alex lui est
plus habitué à coire ce type de distance
donc ça allait à peu près il avait un
petit bobo pied mais a réussi à bien
gérer avant dernière question vous avez
noué des contacts avec certains clubs
qu'est ce qu'ils ont pensé de votre de
votre engagement de de cet événement
c'était assez aléatoire on ce qui était
compliqué effectivement c'est d'entrer
en contact avec les clubs
on a reçu des réponses de la moitié des
clubs 6 sur 12 sur la réponse qu'on a eu
effectivement il était assez étonné
et qu'on fasse de telles distances et
conviennent qu on vienne voir surtout
des petits stades
voilà et puis après comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure nous on a été étonné en
retour de recevoir un accueil comme on a
reçus par exemple à fulham ou sinon à
brentford et à wimbledon le dernier jour
sont des clubs qui nous ont ouvert les
stades et qu'on était vraiment très très
sympathique comme vous avez pu pénétrer
à l'intérieur on est rentré à
l'intérieur on a pris des photos des
vidéos tout ça dernière question un
prochain défi
une prochaine capitale on pense
peut-être à madrid 1 il ya le real
madrid l'atlético de madrid mais il ya
d'autres clubs on peut penser aussi à
munich peut-être ou barcelone même si
vous voulez on a une spécificité c'est
qu'on va quand le ter enfin coco royaume
uni donc peut-être un futur projet
peut-être à manchester à glasgow donc
pour ça il faudrait qu'on trouve un
sponsor donc si on en trouve un on
repart sur sur les causes ou sur
manchester par exemple le brun ou peur
yvelinois c'était le chasseur de stades
des yvelines style salagnac merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur notre plateau
et on continue avec de la marche à pied
à présent non pas du running m'aidera
marche à pied avec thomas d'eric qui a
réalisé son rêve
cet été ce génie ni mon teint de 20 ans
a traversé en totale autonomie pendant
six jours le salar d'uyuni le plus grand
désert de sel du monde c'est en bolivie
il a filmé son aventure à l'aide d'une
caméra au regard des le montage est
signée romain russe fini
[Applaudissements]
oui
je m'apprête à partir
et là c'est réel c'est concret parce
qu'une fois que je serai là dedans je
fais tout seul en totale autonomie sans
gps sans tracker sans balises sans
téléphone satellite
aucun moyen de contacter le reste du
monde donc il y aura que moi et le vide
ça fait quelque chose agca pour cet
après midi jusqu'à ce que je pose mon
plan ce soir et après j'ai une deuxième
lourde pour cuisiner ce soir et pour la
soirée passée au rite parce que j'ai
vraiment très très chaud y'a aucun
espace nombre j'ai soif et je peux pas
boire plus que que mes réserves
tu peux pas tous boire là d'un coup j'ai
obligé de me restreindre et là j'ai soif
c'est vraiment dur
à part la fatigue et l'énervement un peu
de la journée parce que ça a été dur
j'ai quand même super content d'être là
j'ai aucun regret c'est un lieu
incroyable et ça fait partie des choses
que je vais pas vivre tous les jours
dans ma vie donc faux je profite de cet
instant ici je vois rien autour de moi
je crois que je viens de là bas mais je
suis pas totalement sûr je te garder ce
cap
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais vérifier mon cap tous les 100
mètres et tous les 100 mètres je m'en
doute qu en fait j'étais en train de
délier et que je dois changer de
direction du marché avec la boussole
dans la main ça c'est compliqué
[Musique]
je sais pas comment j'ai fait pour toi
une petite astuce on adore mais j'ai
réussi ça brûle on a tort par contre ces
extrêmes ce soir ça va être vraiment une
nuit etc
ma tante à les accrocher à ma de
beauchamp et à mon sac de l'autre côté
et voilà
voilà donc le désert ça trouve ici et je
ne suis plus dedans je suis enfin sorti
du salar d'uyuni j'ai rejoint la terre
les cailloux ça sort sur autre chose que
sur du sel parce que j'en avais marre
d'avoir les fesses toutes blanches à
cause de ça donc voilà c'est la fin de
cette aventure
après 140 km parcouru six jours de
solitude donc des airs de 30 kg dans des
foires de copier une moyenne de 23
kilomètres par jour parcouru ce désert
[Musique]
au programme de ce week-end encore du
football avec le 3e tour de la coupe de
france 17 club yvelinois sur les
terrains notamment les trappistes se
déplace à graisse armes à vider en
seine-et-marne ce dimanche 15 septembre
à 14h30
l'étoile sportive de trappes a lancé sa
saison en régionale 2 avec deux défaites
rien d'alarmant pour les trappistes
encore en phase de reprise avec leur
nouvel entraîneur ludovic gauthier
objectif cette année le maintien le plus
rapidement possible en mars ou en avril
2020 écoutez le nouveau coach il nous
explique sa méthode et c'est d'avoir le
ballon en jeu de possession de
progression à jeu vers l'avant voilà à
la perte du ballon essayer de récupérer
rapidement mais aussi à moi de m'adapter
aussi aux qualités de mes joueurs ça
c'est ma philosophie mais j'ai pas
oublier la qualité de mes joueurs donc
on va essayer de s'adapter à tout ça et
faire un bon championnat
prendre du plaisir c'est plus important
ait eu trois quatre départs moi j'ai
pris mes fonctions très tard à fin juin
début juillet dont 80% du groupe est
resté quand même et j'ai fait signer
deux trois joueurs de l'extérieur la
saison dernière trap a obtenu son ticket
pour la régionale 2 trap a terminé
meilleure défense de la région
parisienne en régionale 3 yanis baroudi
défenseur central a participé à cette
performance il joue à l'étoile sportive
de trappes depuis l'âge de 8 ans
aujourd'hui les capitaines de l'équipe
seniors c'est la séquence trois
questions à yanis baroudi c'est parti
[Musique]
et puis je suis dit c'est rami mon père
était bien dans le foot mais s'inscrit
naturellement et je continue sans sport
d'équipé j'aime bien j'ai l'habitude j'y
joue depuis que futile et grands joueurs
on aime bien la télé c'est venu tout
seul en fait à part sa force et on est
resté dans le foot
la montée c'est une récompense a fait
deux trois ans que je suis senior
on essaie de monter chaque année à
chaque fois ça choix des petites choses
en fin d'année on n'y arrive pas la
dernière on a réussi à faire une bonne
chose on est monté ça s'est bien passé
on a tout donné pendant l'année ça a
payé à la
en effet plus de foot mais maxwell
l'ancien latéral du paris saint germain
est propre c'est un bon joueur j'aime
bien comment il est et je m'inspire
donner c'est de faire pareil en rugby
reprise de la fédérale 3 ce week end les
versaillais promu cette saison après
trois ans en 1ère vont affronter massif
central pour le compte de la première
journée
quels sont les objectifs des joueurs de
la cité royale cette année les réponses
sur des images de michael l hydro ce
mardi au stade de porchefontaine à
versailles les visages sont concentrés à
l'aube de cette nouvelle saison
cette année le club a fait son grand
retour en fédérale 3 après trois ans
d'absence
à ce niveau on va essayer de surfer sur
la dynamique de la dernière puisque on
est sorti d'une très belle saison en
honneur avec deux titres de champion
d'île de france et du coup il ya un
super d'état d'esprit
tous les joueurs qui étaient présents
les dernières sont très contents de
reprendre la saison avec beaucoup
d'impatience et beaucoup beaucoup
d'envié donc c'est plutôt très positif
pour nous puisque notion n'est on a à
coeur de relever les challenges delà de
la fédérale 3 l'objectif cette année le
maintien avec au minimum 10 victoires
pour réussir à atteindre ce chiffre
un recrutement ciblé a été effectué cet
été il ya douze recrues cette saison
principalement faite de fait 3
principalement des des arrières
voilà on verra ça s'intègre avec le
groupe actuellement
normalement ça devrait correspondre à
nos attentes
dans leur poule les versailles et
tomberont notamment contre boulogne
billancourt auxerre ou encore bobigny va
falloir travailler dur dur dur pour
essayer d'être au niveau
être au niveau de la poule parce que on
a une poule qui est qui et qui va tu
assez compliqué à mon sens donc falloir
bien travailler et s'investir deux fois
plus qu'on a pu faire
on est passé premier test ce dimanche 15
septembre à 15 heures sur le terrain de
massif central une victoire et la saison
sera parfaitement lancé et avant de se
quitter regardez ces images la légende
de l'athlétisme carl lewis est rendu
dans les yvelines la semaine dernière un
passage à clairefontaine à la rencontre
des joueurs de l'équipe de france de
football
il s'est rendu ensuite au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
je rappelle car lewis le plus grand
sportif du 21e siècle du 20e siècle par
dont huit titres de champion du monde et
9 médailles d'or olympique en sprint et
en saut en longueur
c'est la fin de ce premier numéro merci
nous avoir suivis pas d'ici là enfin
d'ici la semaine prochaine le prochain
numéro du 7-8 sport passé une excellente
semaine sportive
[Musique]